russ had a huge scoring game the other
night 30 points
against another one of his former teams
houston come on
that's become his stable shot
so often players turn their heads and
look at the driving player and forget
about the fundamental of boxing out
throws it down
look out below score tied at 26.
he's got less than 200 now to catch it
pass carl milano speaking of lebron and
he's got three more right there
porzingis yeah that was the same draft
class as dilo d'angelo russell
yes sir
lebron downtown
yeah that was it
bad play about brazilians he should have
made an effort to get that defensive
rebound well lebron sees nettle in front
of him so he's gonna attack and score
[Applause]
[Music]
austin reeves
played 20 minutes
as much as anyone except for westbrook
lebron high archers good
counting lebron
significantly slower he got nedo on
lebron see if lebron wants to take him
to the basket
trying to body him here comes a double
by kcp
step back lebron is good little fall
back for james lakers have three
starters in double digits led by of
course lebron who started at the five
tonight lebron all the way counted and
one three point opportunity for james
this time gets into the paint gets
leading the nba they led in that
department last year although clutch
games haven't been great lebron
steps into that one
turnover in lebron at work the long
triple the ventures into the paint
now lebron with 29 in the game they are
going to need everything he can deliver
tonight hang in the air with one hand
leaning left shooting right off the
glass he is feeling
good about himself in the lakers
baldwell pope
now to poisons good play by ross double
teaming shoveled at the lebron here he
comes lebron james
throw it down
[Music]
lebron with 11 to shoot he'll organize
things
trying to move into the lane now gonna
go to the baseline where he hits a
13-footer
kuzma is in front of him
lebron now trying to back up clocks down
to three lebron overcools
[Applause]
another look at that shot that lebron
made over cougs
and lebron's third 40-point game he's
underneath making 42
biggest lead of the game and then the
easy layup with no rim protection just
gets to the rim
pittsburgh switches off on him
lebron on the wing lebron
fall back yes sir
he's doing it again
in
that last shot over kiss was just
remarkable that's
44 points for lebron james
kuzma they take it away
lebron the middle man lebron here he
goes spinning all the way kind of it
goes it goes and one
and then a three-point opportunity after
the turnover by kuzma
giving the makers a chance that is very
unlike him
is
[Applause]
50.